SOMEHOW.
>>TRYING TO
SLAM
OUT OF THE PUCK, HERE COMES
>> BRAD ANDERSEN
DeANGELO , AND D FROM CATHOLICS
BACK MIDPOINT, FLAMING SHOTS,
GIVES UP A REBOUND TO THIS YEAR
HERE, LOOK AT ECOVERS ALONG THE
SAVE.
OFTEN THE POSTER.
ALMOST TAKES OFF ANDERSEN AND
GOES INTO THE BACK OF THE BACK
FROM KREBS, BUT TURNED OVER.  P
SCORES!
CAROLINA HIS
SALTINESS, BUT HE BRINGS THAT I
NOW IN FRONT OF ANDERSEN.
BEING
PRETTY MUCH THE FULL PERIOD HAS
BEEN THE CAROLINA HURRICANES.
SO FOR THEM
CENTERS AREA ANDERSEN TRYING TO
FREEZE OF THE A A  PASTOR THE D
IF YOU WATCH , AS
THIS ONE HERE, OFF THE BACK OF
>> Ryan: MIDDLE . SHOT
IS.
YOU HAVE TO PLACE THAT'S
ABSOOF HIS GOALS SEEM TO BE BIG
ONES FOR THIS SABRES TEAM THIS
OPPORTUNITIES.
HE BEATS HIS D MAN OFF THE SHOT
HE CENTERS, AND NIEDERREITER
SCORES.
THE TEAM IS TIED TS THAT, IT IS
QUICK ONE TIMER RIGHT BETWEEN
H
2-2, THE SCORE.
HERE COMES AHO IN FOR
THERE.
THAT IS USUALLY WHERE HE IS
TAKING ONE TIMERS ON THE POWER
CLOSER.
>> Ryan: A PENALTY UPCOMING.
AND FALO LEADS WITH 6:23 LEFT
TO GO IN POWER PLAY, AND
THE LEAD ONE, TWO LAB SET UP.
THIS IS A HUGE GOAL FOR